[Music]
the butterfly
it's one of the greatest most beautiful
wonders of nature
its wings
its colors
its motion
it's also one of apple's worst
inventions ever
yes i'm talking about it's butterfly
keyboard
okay first question what are these
butterfly keys anyway
it's the flatter keyboard found on most
of apple's current laptops including the
new macbook air and macbook pros
now there's a reason these keyboards are
named after this stunning insect
under these keys is what is called yes
you guessed it the butterfly mechanism
but to understand it we need to back up
and talk about the scissor mechanism
found under the keys of most laptops
like a scissor the piece is interlocked
when pressed down
that structure is taller so when apple
wanted to make its laptops thinner it
came up with the butterfly mechanism
like a real butterfly it has wings that
flap down when pressed
[Music]
so what's wrong with wings well a lot
apparently some people who have used all
three generations of this keyboard with
models made in 2015 through 2019 have
experienced issues
big issues
some keys don't register some keys it
registers twice so you get a double
letter sometimes the keys get stuck
and i've had most of those issues with
the e key and sometimes the r key on my
new macbook air
why does that happen i headed to simple
mac a mac repair shop here in new york
city to find out
[Music]
so how often do you see this happen we
see this a lot
we see a lot of customers coming with
these butterfly keyboards when i asked
tony what he thought could be causing
this he explained that when a small
piece of dust or debris gets stuck in
the butterfly mechanism there's so
little room under it that it can cause
the whole thing to get stuck there have
been so many issues with this keyboard
design that apple will fix the first and
second generation keyboards free for up
to four years after purchase
apple supposedly fixed the problem using
elastic membranes to block debris in the
third generation keyboard found on the
new macbook pro and macbook air
but it hasn't stopped the problems
we are aware that a small number of
users are having issues with their third
generation butterfly keyboard and for
that we are sorry the vast majority of
mac notebook users are having a positive
experience with the keyboard an apple
spokesperson said
should 1200 plus laptops be breaking
from dust and debris
absolutely not but at least there's
something you can do about it
number one know your warranty
laptops with the third generation
keyboard should still be under apple's
year-long warranty if you have any issue
take it to an apple store now says apple
number two try unshaky
a developer wrote an app called unshaky
that helps get rid of repeat key presses
if the software senses a second
keystroke within a few milliseconds it
will kill it it's beta homegrown
software so proceed at your own risk but
it has worked out well for me
number three
get a can of air or try an external
keyboard
an upset
[Music]
number four get another laptop
i love this macbook air but the keyboard
issues have been so aggravating i'd
consider a windows pc like this surface
book or maybe just go back to the glory
days of 2015 with this vintage macbook
pro
i think we can all agree apple needs to
return to keyboards that well
work
the butterfly keyboard needs to make
like a real butterfly
and fly far
far away
so what's wrong with wings i'm not doing
this